the DA's office The Fulton County Court
Clerk's Office referred to a quote
fictitious document that has been
circulated online
as if to
argue
the document isn't actually from them
and it's being shared randomly yet
Reuters has Georgia Court website
briefly publishes removes document about
about potential Trump charges it's a
pretty serious allegation from them if
they're saying Reuters fabricated a
document and that's what's being
circulated online wow that's a bold
claim right that's their defense well
here's the story either
there's a seditious conspiracy against
Donald Trump using the court system or
Reuters fabricated the news to smear
opponents of Donald Trump and Reuters is
a wire service so like it's where a lot
of news originates everywhere if they're
the ones fabricating the news that would
be deeply concerning so should Reuters
file a lawsuit against the person who's
claiming that they are are you
defamation I mean maybe